is too much weight to gain in a
relationship that is disrespectful to
you
[Music]
today do you get any wiggle room per kid
yeah let me know all right
[Music]
um
20 pounds plus you putting on 20 pounds
plus wait what's that in kg I can't even
think in pounds we'll see what's that in
kg makes no sense I don't know that's
about I think in power I don't know one
and a half Stars kg that would be like
wow like three stones if you put on
three stone that's a bit mad yeah three
stone is mad
because you know that's gonna happen and
then but you but you would eventually
expect that you know you're gonna put in
some some work to get that to get that
back why because you see loads of men
age 40 plus with things like beer
bellies what are they doing girl I was
gonna ask you yeah
I get that but men but but women women
like men for different things they don't
like that
men are more visuals so that's why that
women will date anybody like women will
get with any man do you know what I mean
they don't they're not looking at you
for like some some women like the bib
the beer but that's that's what they
like they like they like bellies they
like you know man boobs and all that
kind of thing that's what they like
okay but do you think it's more to do
with not so much they're putting on
weight but if you feel like they're not
taking care of themselves anymore
and they don't dress well but that's it
is the inactivity for me okay would you
pick would you pick a girl that gained
no weight but dressed like a bum or a
girl that like dressed really well
within 50 pounds why not dressed like a
bum yeah yeah that one that's what I
really like like weight is the ultimate
form of like letting go to my to man
right would you say yeah from since
you've been in school we've all know it
the girl that was fine and slim and
active in school you walk past there
when you 29 30 you don't even recognize
her oh
it's you yeah how many times I've done
that from school like oh how are you
doing how's it how's the kids and you
don't want to say it well but you know
what's going on well and the one thing
is if you look at women like back from
like the 20s and 30s and you look at old
pictures they all bounce back after
pregnancy even in like the 1800 oh my
God those those women had like three
times the amount of kids we did and they
all they all look good
yep
main thing it just shows like you just
don't care in it like if if you put an
effort to
get back in shape or stay in shape when
you get into relationship it just shows
that you're putting in effort in your
care so as a collective Collective you
guys said 20 pounds you said 20. you'll
give your girl 20. that's something
excuse me some kids yeah like yeah yeah
okay okay no he's like ah maybe not 20.
you're not not 20. once it starts going
over 20 I'm gonna be like babe come on
it depends on how you look because some
some women put on weight but but okay
his foot is falling in the right places
but if it starts becoming you you're
you're not in control of it if I can see
that you're not in control of your
weight gain that's a problem because if
it's purposeful because if it's
purposeful weight gain there's there's a
certain lifestyle that goes with that
you know I mean it could you can wait
you can put on weight like you know what
I mean in certain areas uh that will
that will shape your body and make it
look like boom but if you if if you're
not if you're not in control if I can
see that that weight gain although it
looks good you didn't know why you
gained that weight how you gain that
weight then I would be like then that
would be a red flag for me so would you
give her 30 pounds how much roughly you
can see give me a ride I'd eat it in kg
or I would say I would say 10 I would
say 10
to 15 kg is nuts I'll do 15 kgs I'm sure
that's about 20 pounds
33 pounds 33 pounds yeah 10 to 15 kgs
that's a lot but the thing is you can
put that on you can put that kind of
weight on but be in shape you know that
yeah so but if you if I can see that
you're not you're that's not your
lifestyle yeah but you could be in shape
but like I I've been bigger but and I
was still in shape like I was doing
CrossFit and stuff but I was eating like
[ __ ] and so it you can you can be doing
the exercises but if you're eating like
[ __ ] it doesn't matter but I think
that's what I mean I think that's I
think that's what it is it's like I can
see that you're not you're not in
control you're just eating like [ __ ]
although you're maybe a little bit
active you're not necessarily
structuring your body right yeah so yeah
I I guess what you're saying is like if
she's like actively like bodybuilding
and putting on weight productively but
if you're just 30 pounds of muscle yeah
well that's what I'm saying so that's
great yeah
about that that's a lot that's why I
said once you start going past the 20
pounds Mark yo sorry girls in college we
gained 10 20 pounds they'd be like it's
muscle cause I was an athlete but I'm
like well you did not get like you know
how hard it is to gain 20 pounds of
muscle you freaking bodybuilder that's
what I'm saying like once it cost to go
that 20 that 20 it's like yeah you you
don't desire me you don't actually
respect me yeah you're looking at it
you're looking at it like you don't rape
me dude I feel like that's a form of
disrespect absolutely kind of yeah so
you you give her 20. you're a little
more generous you give her 30.
you a little more generous all right
what about one extra cake you know what
I don't know if I could actually say
wait but what I do feel is that if you
ask your girlfriend to stop putting on
weight and she doesn't make no effort at
all to change something then I feel like
it's an issue so we could say it for
like that's a limit I would say what
at least 10 yeah I know what he's saying
about this you can put on 10. you can
put on some crazy weight like that you
can put on weight and still get 10
pounds it's crazy 10 pounds that's crazy
yeah yeah yeah he said 10 15. 10 kgs
guys the weight that she's already at
like from the way that you meet her like
that's what you're counting for yeah 10
pounds is a bit in it 10 kg That's Heavy
bro
15 KGI you violin it's 20 kgs I just
don't understand why it's like you have
a man why wouldn't you try to keep him
right like in the clip like you have a
man why don't you try to keep him why
they don't have no games
why are you like why are you only going
to lose the weight after you guys break
up because they realize once as I said
it's like women have the same kind of
like you know like they say about men
like the notch is in our bed and
whatever women have their own thing too
like you are getting more sex than
anybody in the world you are the ones
who are The Gatekeepers to sex so when
you realize that it's like once you get
a guy to only focus on you and only
spend your time on you you go sour
treat a mean keep them Keen I never made
that up how can it come from me that
came from before I was born and it still
works to this day because the every time
I chase the girl down or you try to do
that extra
air
second I turn my back on her and and
I'm out this restaurant with this thing
I'm going bowling with this girl I'm
watching wakanda with this one even
though I told you I was going to watch a
review and you see that oh now my
phone's ringing oh what are you doing
oh you want to know what I'm doing
because you see me doing stuff but when
I was paying you mine you didn't want to
hear me what kind of forever with
someone else yeah Oh I thought you were
gonna watch that with me you wasn't
available
okay let me let me get the status one I
understand the situation so you're with
the girl and you're interested and then
she's curving you yeah so when I'm
paying attention she'll cover me and
then you say you know what I'm gonna
move on yeah I'm I'm on the bigger and
better things absolutely this girl over
here is interested so I'm gonna go talk
to her absolutely and maybe she was a
side chick that got promoted
he came in through the right door she
didn't come in through the side chick
though she came in your favorite meals
there we go she started paying attention
she became a Kung Fu student
started studying so she comes in and
then you take that attention away now
girl one comes back and says now I'm
interested now you'll say chick oh now
she's been devoted now you demoted oh
and that's how the Vicious Cycle goes
around so so in a way the side chick
could become the main
well no because the way he came into the
door the girl that I didn't meet she was
just a complete random oh it was random
yeah random I don't know what level of
status she was in with other her other
relationships but if you come in in the
same doorway You're Gonna Leave the
title
yeah but see I tried to I try to offer
the main thing entrance to the first
thing and she denied it the door closed
forever membership close you're never
gonna get the main main chick treatment
ever again so now by the time she comes
back the only dude that's available for
her is side chick she's gonna take it
every time okay but why didn't you take
it to begin with because she thought she
was entitled and she thought she she
thought I wasn't the price so so she
wasn't treating you like it came
absolutely so you treated her like a
peasant absolutely
right here
side door absolutely okay Down the Hatch
okay okay so so you said roughly 20.
he's the most generous one here 30
pounds to hey what country are you from
Nigeria Jamaica okay that's why that's
why you had an extra 10 pounds all right
let me just clarify
that is that is the that is the leeway
but it needs to come back down
how long does she have so she's she's at
30 almost 31 Pounds okay if if how long
she got to lose it
if there was no if there's no reason
other than you're eating in your
lifestyle shitty then really you've got
immediately you need this is you need to
I I know yeah because I I've had a
personal training past yeah so I know
how long it takes it would take with
with if you're really active and you
wanted to get it done yeah it would take
you maybe three months maybe to maybe
three months four months of proper like
regimented regime you see it you got me
so she got three months
how much how much for you I don't know
about pounds but like uh 34 Stone of
course all right Max what's the
difference I don't freestone's heavy
three stones and probably about the same
to be honest uh no you're the most
generous one here
there you go hey hey hey hey hey is your
girlfriend watching this show
okay now same question for the woman do
you think it's disrespectful if your man
lets himself go yes yes what do you
think
um depends on the circumstances okay
exactly you might be ill or okay outside
of extreme circumstances
well if he's just been lazy and
then yeah I wouldn't say disrespectful
just just give me the ick okay I want to
feel disrespected personally I just
think ugh so what would give you the egg
is it a certain amount of weight
no I think it's the whole the lazy the
laziness element of it the sloth
it goes back to Lifestyle that whatever
they're eating like they've stopped
going to the gym they've stopped working
out they're they're eating lots of like
takeaways that's obviously making them
get fat that's gross that's right it's
like it's the mindset like are you
are you just
not make an effort to do anything at all
like I can understand if you're working
really hard you'd have time you're
really tired blah blah but if you're
just at home all day every day playing
computer games
sitting around depressed like most men
yeah hold on let me let me ask a
question so say serious that's how
that's it that's how most men experience
life right now so are you gonna come and
motivate him or are you going to find
that other dude Who's got what you like
yeah how long does he have
three months
to be more socially acceptable for a man
to be fat than it would a woman it's
almost frowned upon like oh my God she's
put on 30 pounds I mean you would think
women would be thinner than I mean
statistically men are thinner than women
like if that was true the woman would be
thinner
like if anything it's like it's more
socially acceptable for women to be
overweight because there's women's body
positivity people never frown upon men
putting on white but when women do it
it's like oh my God all the men are like
she's put on so much weight she's this
she's that but my yeah they put her in
there they put him on the magazine yeah
magazines now the body but you don't see
men's body positivity that's just women
you don't say like the short man what
like the you know like there's no short
man body positivity movement nope
out here advocating for short men you're
broke shaming me
literally
can I can I ask you so say say for
instance those um your your man was uh
he was earning uh 300 000 a year okay
but he was getting fat um
no I don't want him to get fat I can
provide for myself I don't care about
his money he ain't getting fat as long
as if if I know I can't get fat why
should he get fat fair enough it's as
simple as that what I'm hearing is is
the conditional money would hang about
with the belly basically
circumcision yeah you opened up the
portal because circumstances would
change now whether they can have a
Bailey or not or so this is if I was
bringing home 300 Grand and I put on 40
pounds would you stay with me absolutely
no of course
I'll tell you I'll tell you I'll tell
you the difference though it's like what
women are attracted to men for their
like jobs their status like that sort of
thing but men don't care what you do for
a living so your money is nothing we're
like their money is something to us from
the beginning like I said men are born
without value we have to build our
status from about five we know from
about five years old we have to make
something of ourselves women are born
with value you can just show up and
somebody is going to help you out
it's like if you ask for a time in the
street versus iOS for the time in the
street it's gonna be a lot harder
because women are just naturally
accepted in society for most things
women and children first like we know
this this is what we we've kind of been
raised on so it's different for us it's
always going to be different that's why
you see fat Rich Italian Mafia bosses
with slim pretty ass wives and they make
sure they stay in the gym and look good
because they know a heartbeat they can
be replaced by the 21 22 23 year old I
don't give a cat don't care as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on
and if you want to help please consider
sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible